hello everybody good morning and welcome
to Sky News breakfast
huddles are bracing themselves for what
NHS England warns will be exceptionally
low Staffing in some regions as nurses
go on strike from eight o'clock tonight
the Royal College of Nursing is pushing
ahead with the bank holiday walkout
after it and fellow Union unite voted
against a government payoffer other
unions including Unison and the GMB
voted in favor the health secretary
Steve Barkley released a statement last
night and part of it says it's hugely
disappointing some unions are escalating
strike action this week including the
RCN despite only a third of its members
rejecting the government's fair and
reasonable offer on pay which other
unions accepted the rcn's decision not
to provide any national exemptions from
Strike action including for emergency
and Cancer Care also risks patient
safety though I welcome the fact the
number of local mitigations have been
agreed for critical services
General Secretary of the RCN said this
this morning the government wants to
bring NHS strike action to a close this
coming week but with several big unions
and nursing as the largest part of the
NHS still in dispute it has to do better
so that's a pat Cullen of the RCN that's
what she said this morning well let's
bring in Skye's uh shiman Freeman Powell
who's here with us now so this latest
stripe by nurses gets underway as we say
at eight o'clock tonight how much
concern is there about the disruption to
patients but also Fizz about patient
safety as well
NHS bosses are urging members of the
public to use the Health Service wisely
over the bank holiday whilst this strike
action takes place so it probably is a
good idea for people not to do anything
too wild over this weekend that may land
themselves in hospital because this
strike action will impact half of
England's hospitals it will also impact
Mental Health Services and Community
Services too and for the first time
actually it's likely to impact intensive
care as well and that's because unlike
previous strike action the Royal College
of nurses haven't made any national
exemptions but like you just alluded to
they have made some local exemptions
which has been welcomed by NHS bosses
but they are still warning that the
impacts of patient care could be
significant which is what the NHS
English medical director told us earlier
on
nurses are 25 of the NHS Workforce so
they are a very significant part of our
Workforce and it is very difficult to
manage services uh without them now I
know that the public Have Heard on a
number of occasions are say are saying
that this is one of the most significant
areas of industrial action uh for us in
the NHS but I do want to emphasize that
this is significant
so that was NHS England's medical
director explaining how significant this
strike action would be and the impact
it's likely to have on patients of
course nurses will argue that this is
the reason they're striking to begin
with because of poor working conditions
which has been caused in part by low pay
which is what they will argue but this
is obviously against the backdrop of an
already struggling NHS trying to catch
up with millions of appointments that
have been canceled over recent years and
of course more appointments are likely
to be canceled as a result of continuing
strike action however despite the impact
to the nhsc bosses are still asking
members to the public to continue using
999 if it is a life-threatening
situation okay Siobhan thanks very much
indeed and just to let you know that the
Royal College of Nursing boss Pat Cullen
is one of the guests coming up on Sophie
rich on Sunday that's at 8 30 this
morning
now the last UK evacuation flight left
Sudan last night ending an operation
that's brought nearly 2 000 people out
of the country as it Teeters on the
brink of Civil War most are British
Nationals and their dependents though
there was a last-minute decision to also
allow NHS Doctors Without British
passports to board the final flights the
foreign office said the operation was
the largest evacuation of any Western
Nation from the country
well thousands more have fled the
fighting not only by air but also by
water and land countries including the
UK Germany France Canada and the
Netherlands have flown Nationals from
the Wadi saeedna Airfield just north of
Khartoum in total Britain has evacuated
1 888 people with the majority flying to
Cyprus and then onto the UK
those who couldn't fly to safety have
been seeking Refuge by Crossing Sudan's
land borders more than 20 000 people
have fled into Chad where authorities
have voiced concerns over what that
could do to the neighboring countries
stability
Egypt has seen more than 16 000 people
enter from its Southern border with
Sudan while more than 14 000 people have
entered South Sudan to escape the
violence
smaller numbers have also traveled to
the Central African Republic and to
Ethiopia
and ferries and Naval vessels have been
transporting people to Jeddah in Saudi
Arabia from Port Sudan from where our
Africa correspondent usra elberger said
this report
in the shadow of an old British colonial
building is a new British effort
after Mass complaints of inaction UK
Consular support is now underway and
their base has shifted from the heart of
the conflict in the capital to Port
Sudan I mean at a first glance it
doesn't look great it's a bit chaotic
but it is a much better option than
what's out there these people have
traveled a long way and they get some
water supplies and an opportunity to
potentially leave on an evacuation
mission of foreign Nationals and people
who have documentation to go abroad
the foreign office has advised British
Nationals to come here if they need help
leaving Sudan as unscheduled chartered
ships arrive from Saudi Arabia to
evacuate foreigners
some have departed and others patiently
wait hoping to qualify
if you have you know
a foreign passport
or any I think that will actually give
you the chance to go outside
you will take it and this is why
everybody here is doing his best to go
out of sugar and what about people who
don't have American passports your
family your friends I feel sorry for
them you know because the situation is
not good I you know everything if they
could have this you know document so
they can leave you know because you know
it's terrible there people are drained
from the shock not only of violence but
abrupt separation who would you have
brought with you here if you could
family technically sometimes I just feel
like when I'm leaving I feel like a
traitor to my country I'm leaving them
in all this pain while I'm going to go
and have joy I feel like sometimes you
feel like a trainer for doing that I
don't know why
across town more people wait
exposed to the Searing heat with little
support we want to go back out because
every person here is no have money no
you can say sleep out on the out areas
not in the hotels not in the all people
says sleeping on the roads
location you know the cleaning that's a
good
the quality of the waiting room varies
by passport just like the chances of
evacuation a lottery for a better life
that starts at Birth
Sky News Port Sudan
thank you sir joins me now from Port
Sudan
um so what's the latest situation
they're used for how's it looking there
I mean people here are still scrambling
to evacuate some have been given the
opportunity some haven't there is a lot
of organizing on a community level
people giving out food and supplies but
they're very limited there's really no
humanitarian response presence on the
ground we haven't seen the United
Nations on the ground we haven't seen
any other of the international
ngos that operate in Sudan actually
giving people shelter the shelter that
we saw at the Port yesterday protecting
people from scorching Sun you know 40
degree heat was actually a community
initiative so people here do feel
abandoned this is a feeling that they've
had for a while as you and led mediation
failed between the two generals that we
have seen now destroy the capital those
that do get to leave seem to be those
that have foreign passports some of them
have been collecting in certain areas
and there are still lots of foreign
Nationals that haven't been able to get
on about on a ship that haven't been
able to get on a plane and instead have
gotten on a bus to the border to Egypt
so there have been people that have been
left behind by embassies and and
governments of foreign countries that we
actually yes last night were taken to a
building that had been booked entirely
by the United Nations incredibly
beautiful building and people here
asking why is the United Nations not
offering temporary shelter at the very
least for the people that have fled this
conflict the numbers now are looking at
at least 75 000 people displaced so far
and the conflict is still ongoing every
ceasefire that we have heard uh be
announced has only partially held in the
capital fighting has still continued
Hospital are shutting down a msf
supported hospital was actually attacked
and destroyed and there are many other
situations like this so the question is
when will the International Community
respond in any sort of way I'm not
saying adequately I'm not saying I'm on
a massacre I'm saying just respond to
people here the evacuations have been
led by countries uh eager to get their
citizens out and even that even then the
Brits the British government has been
criticized for its delayed response but
we are yet to see an adequate response
on the ground that is supporting people
through this crisis
you sir thanks very much indeed
well the former Sudanese prime minister
Abdullah hamdog says a full Civil War
would be a nightmare for the world
he spoke at a conference in Kenya as
fighting continues to puncture a fragile
ceasefire he said it's effectively a
conflict between two armies which are
both well-armed and well trained
now Millions watching next weekend's
coronation will be invited to swear
allegiance of the king out loud with the
public being offered an active role in
the ceremony for the first time the
homage of the people will replace the
homage of the peers who traditionally
kneel and make a pledge to the Monarch
in person
well people will say will be asked to
say this I swear that I will pay true
allegiance to your majesty and to your
heirs and successes according to the law
so help meet God
well the pledge is among several new
details of King Charles's coronation
including the Liturgy the prayers and
actions of the service it will have the
theme called to serve and
representatives from the nation's Faith
communities will play an active role in
the coronation
also in a break with tradition Camilla
will be anointed as Queen in full public
View
and a reminder that we have a special
and exclusive augmented reality web
experience of the crown to show you it's
been launched on the Sky News app on
your mobile phones and essentially puts
a life-size crown for you to look at in
detail and you can have a go Yourself by
scanning the QR code on your mobile
phone well our Royal commentator
Alistair Bruce has given it a try
for the first time you can experience
the crown in your own home just press
this button and it will materialize in
front of you and then you can walk
around it you can engage with it and you
will know as much as anyone else does
about the crown that will be used at the
coronation on the 6th of May
let's go back on to our top story and
nurses in England are due to Stage
walkouts from 8 pm tonight and through
the bank holiday joining us now is the
chief executive of NHS employers and
deputy chief executive of the NHS
Confederation Danny Mortimer a very good
morning to you so nurses will go on
strike tonight for 28 hours at what
impact do you expect that to have
well
um the strike is taking place in half of
the um trusts in in England
um the RCN didn't have a successful
mandate for strike action in the other
half we are expecting a significant
impact
um thankfully the asean have agreed in a
significant number of places to now
um put in place mitigations to allow uh
staff who would otherwise be striking to
work and that's welcome indeed it's it's
happened later than NHS leaders would
have liked but it does provide some
extra support but I think this will be
the strike that has the biggest impact
of all of all the strikes we've seen in
this last six months
How concerned are you about patient
safety
there have been real concerns about the
risk to patients in recent days and as I
said the RCN have responded to the
requests that have been made to them and
to encourage staff in certain areas our
areas caring for our sickest patients
our sickest children in particular and
they have encouraged those otherwise
strikingnesses to commit to work uh in
the uh During the period of strike and
that's very welcome indeed and that will
make a difference but we are very
worried about the impact that's having
and we will see much lower levels of
Staffing than we would otherwise see and
that we've seen on previous strike days
as well
give us an idea of what morale is like
in the health service at the moment
well clearly as you've seen through the
period of strike action there are real
concerns from NHS staff across all sorts
of Staff groups of course that's been
about the pay awards that have been made
to NHS staff in recent years by the by
the government but it also as your your
viewers will have seen it also reflects
a concern
um about what staff are seeing uh in
relation to the care they can provide
their patients no one in a Health
Service is happy about the weights that
patients are having to experience across
all sorts of all sorts of services
um the picture is different in different
places and different Departments of
course but coming off the back of the
pandemic that we are undoubtedly seeing
real concerns amongst the people who
work in the Health Service about the
position they find themselves in there
are things that can make a difference in
the longer term and the government is
due to publish a Workforce plan we
believe a little bit later in May and
and that will make a difference that
will give people working in the Health
Service some hope that help is coming
um and that the government is prepared
to invest in increasing the numbers of
people who are being trained to work in
the health centers
in the meantime Health unions are split
on whether to accept the government's
pay offer but it is likely that when
there's an overall vote on it this week
um the pay rise will get the backing
that's the likely outcome so what do you
think happens next and what do you think
that means for the prospect of future
action by the unions that have rejected
the payoff of the RCN and unite what do
you think that could mean for strike
action in the months ahead
the picture is a really complicated one
and of course we've we've still got a
dispute between our Junior doctors and
the government as well
um
my organization has said that it it does
wish that the RCN had waited until the
position for other trade unions uh was
clearer and the approach we take in the
Health Service is a connected one and
for our non-medical pay we work with all
the unions we recognize 12 or 13 across
all our various staff groups and as you
said the biggest Union Unison have voted
to accept the pay deal so the picture is
complicated what we do know is that the
RCN have to balance again their mandate
for strike action
ends at midnight on Monday they had
planning to strike on Tuesday but as we
saw this week a judge was very clear
that the Mandate had expired that if
nurses had gone on strike on Tuesday the
RCN would have placed them in a position
outside of the law and so they have to
they have to ballot again
um so we won't know the response and
attitude of nurses if the pay award
um does go ahead and is paid
um in the spring and summer
okay well Danny Mortimer we really
appreciate your time this morning chief
executive of NHS employers thanks very
much indeed
well also this morning the labor leader
has again defended his party's use of
attack ads on Rishi sunak including one
which suggests that the Prime Minister
doesn't want convicted sex offenders
jailed tsukistama was pressed about the
adverts by its guys Sophie Ridge
now normally in interviews this program
I try and kind of look forward but I
just want to go back to something if I
may because I think it's quite important
and if I'm being honest I don't feel
like you've been properly kind of
questions about it so at the beginning
of April labor published an attack at
which had a picture of Rishi sunak and
it said do you think adults convicted of
sexually assaulting children should go
to prison which she seen that doesn't
now you've since said that you stand by
every word of that right so do you
kirstma believe that Rishi suno thinks
that pedophile should not go to jail is
that what you're saying the figures
speak for themselves no I'm not talking
about the figures because we're talking
about what it says here in the ad do you
think adults convicting convicted of
sexually assaulting children should go
to prison that doesn't yeah is that what
you think
I think if he did think they should go
to prisoner do something about it so you
don't think he thinks Peter Paul should
go to prison is that what you're
seriously saying I stand by the advert
is that so that's what the advert says
is that what you're seriously saying yes
I think that as prime minister you take
responsibility for what happens in your
criminal justice system he's not taking
responsibility for it and this idea that
somehow you can ship in a new prime
minister we've had five of them now in
the last 13 years and that somehow he
doesn't bear responsibility they have
broken our criminal justice systems
do you take personal responsibility then
for every child abuser who escaped
prison while were you a director of
public prosecutions I take full
responsibility for every decision of the
crown prosecution service
you can see that full interview on
Sophie Ridge on Sunday that's coming up
at 8 30 this morning
in the meantime at some of the day's
other headlines this morning and cold
calls which cheat people out of money by
selling sham Financial products will be
banned under government plans to be
announced next week the Prime Minister
Richardson act says fraudsters Must Be
Stopped from infiltrating their way into
people's lives
the guardian has apologized for a
controversial cartoon of outgoing BBC
chairman Richard Sharp which was widely
condemned as anti-semitic the cartoon
was taken down from the guardian's
website with a message saying that it
didn't meet their editorial standards
the artist Martin Rosen has also
apologized for what he called his
carelessness and thoughtlessness
tens of thousands of protesters in
Israel have maintained pressure over
contentious judicial reforms with more
mass demonstrations the Prime Minister
Benjamin netanyahu's governing Coalition
wants to diminish a judge's ability to
rule against the government or veto
legislation Mr Netanyahu has delayed the
reforms but is pushing ahead with them
a leading blood cancer charity is urging
people from ethnic minorities to
register as stem cell donors black and
Asian people in particular are being
called to come forward after a plunger
the number of overall donors Alice
Porter reports
Antoinette a mum of two has incurable
blood cancer
she's been looking for a stem cell donor
for nine years myeloma has
um Ruined My Life
um
I've had to go through chemotherapy
eight different types of chemotherapy
throughout the years
just before the pandemic I gained 13
spinal fractures because the myeloma had
spread to my spine
if someone came forward and I you know
they matched for me
although it wouldn't cure me it would
give me my best chances of survival if I
were to receive a match I could have
another
20 years maybe Plus
people who are black Asian or from an
ethnic minority background have a 37
chance of finding the best possible stem
cell donor match but for people who are
white it's 72 percent and campaigners
want to change this inequality
patients are mostly matched with a donor
from the same ethnicity as themselves
the problem is fewer people come forward
to register as a potential donor from
ethnic minority backgrounds
within our community there's been lots
of myths and fears and taboos about
giving something of yourself
triggered a lot by what's been done
historically to the black race through
hundreds and hundreds of years
especially clinical research so what
we've had to do is educate
um our community to get people to really
appreciate that my ethnicity can be of a
real assistance to someone
after hearing a campaign on the radio to
recruit more donors from ethnic
minorities Natasha joined the UK stem
cell register
15 years later she saves someone's life
I remember getting the call to say that
we think you're a match which was
incredible so I was straight away what
do I need to do next like get me get me
there
we had oh I had the best nurses that I
couldn't have been asked for more they
looked after you they kept you informed
with everything to be honest I'll do it
tomorrow in a heartbeat it was the best
experience
Antoinette continues to wait for her
match but time is running out
Alice Porter Sky News
possible
a Manhunt is underway for a 38 year old
suspect after a shooting in the Texas
town of Cleveland Police say Francisco
oropeza opened fire on Neighbors after
they asked him to stop firing rounds in
his yard
Sky's U.S correspondent Mark Stone has
the latest
well beyond the tragedy of every mass
shooting here in the United States there
are always particular and peculiar
details with each one and in this case
the details are are utterly horrific it
was 11 30 on Friday night a family had
complained to their neighbor that he was
being too loud because he was firing his
AR-15 assault style rifle in his front
yard and they were trying to get their
baby to go to sleep he according to the
Sheriff's Department responded by saying
I'll do what I like in my front yard he
then went into their house inside and
opened fire he shot five people four of
them died where they were shot the fifth
and eight-year-old child was later Taken
to hospital where they later died the
sheriff's department has said that the
shootings were almost execution style in
their nature it gets worse still because
uh three more children were taken to
hospital covered in blood they were not
injured physically but mentally goodness
knows how injured they are because they
were discovered underneath the bodies of
two of the women that were shot in the
house so five people in total shot
utterly horrific details uh this um is
the 175th mass shooting in the United
States this year and we are only just
approaching the end of April
Joe Biden has spoken at the White House
Correspondents Dinner an evening known
for politicians and journalists making
fun of each other but it had a serious
side as the president called for the
release of the Wall Street Journal
reporter Evan gerskovich who's detained
in Russia accused of spying which he
denies he also spoke about Austin Tice
who disappeared while reporting in Syria
more than a decade ago tonight
is this journalism is not a crime
Evan and Austin should be released
immediately along with every other
American hell hostage or wrongfully
detained abroad
or they want them and their families to
know
children I understand we see them
they are not forgotten
and I promise you
I am working like hell to get them home
but the president didn't pass up
opportunities to make some jokes
including about his own age you say I
mentioned
I say I'm wise
the same over the hill
Don Lemon would say that's a man in his
prime
I'm going to turn this over to Roy
apart him is yours
I'm going to be fine with your jokes
but I'm not sure about dark Brandon
[Applause]
Alan Rickman is being celebrated by
Google today marking 36 years since one
of his first leading theater
performances the late actor opened his
Broadway performance as the anti-hero LA
Vicon de valmore in the production of
liaison dangerous in 1987. a year later
he became more famous for his villainous
role in the action film die hard before
going on to play Professor Snape in
Harry Potter he died in 2016 age 69.
still to come here on skyne's breakfast
the business secretary gets support for
her so-called war on woke and listross
and Rao over missing bunk robes we'll be
taking a look at what's making the news
in the Sunday papers
[Music]
time now to take another look at the
Sunday papers here with us to review
them this morning are the broadcaster
and journalist Thomas Copeland and the
entrepreneur Kate Hardcastle so welcome
back to both of you and Kate we're
kicking off with you um this time around
and a story in the Sunday Telegraph
about John Lewis so talk us through it
well the story focuses on the fact that
because it suggests of people working
from home or therefore head office
workers who might not have those
in-store roles preferring to have a
hybrid existence between the office and
working from home that the store is uh
that the business is looking to reduce
down that very famous London HQ but
there's more to this than meets the eye
John Lewis has become probably one of
the challenge brands in retail now that
really the media particularly are
looking to us as we commentators on
what's happening there and is it
relevant is it retrospective of what's
going on with the way that consumers buy
is a brand that was much love still is
really but has certainly come out of
favor with a lot of buyers it's had a
lot of challenges of light starting the
year with two percent down and saying
that it wouldn't be paying uh the usual
bonus which a lot of stuff there depend
on so a brand going through much
Evolution we've heard talk from the
chair uh James Sharon White about how
she sees this move into to a brand
that's representative and has more
leading into Finance offers banking
offers even home rentals but the main
retail organization certainly needs to
get better and heal and become
Progressive and relevant to a consumer
that we see today with of course a huge
amount of competition in the marketplace
so it's interesting that yes we will
start to see a lot of those big hqs in
London start to move and evolve just as
we've seen the footholding of retail
organizations have become smaller on
high streets because it's about the
quality of offer not just the quantity
yeah it's so interesting how retail is
going to have to adapt to you know cost
of living crisis and high rents on the
High Street and people working from home
there's so many challenges aren't there
really interesting to see what direction
that that takes us in and let's move on
to the Observer Shelby Thomas because
there's an article about Andrew Tate and
how much schools discuss him um in The
Observers so what are they saying there
the government's decided to weigh on
this a little bit the department for
Education advising some schools that
they shouldn't be talking about Andrew
Tate for people who don't know Andrew
titson uh an influencer I suppose
um has pretty unique in the scale of the
influence that he's managed to amass
over a relatively short period of time
he's sort of labeled the king of toxic
masculinity talks a lot about
um and has had some real influence over
over young people especially young boys
in in this article it pretty much
catalogs case after case of a horrendous
example of young boys
um behaving uh really inappropriately
towards young girls in their schools
often pretty categorically quoting or
inspired by Andrew Tate many instances
in here not repeatable on air
um and cases and reports to Charities
and to the government of of misogyny and
sexual harassment in schools going up so
the Department of Education at the
moment is saying we we advise that
schools do not talk about Andrew Tate
their concern is that he will become
promoted as a consequence of talking
about him more not entirely sure I mean
I think there's room for disagreement
there that's probably the case that if
you don't address this stuff in schools
head on it will Fester it needs to be
addressed properly and actually if you
don't have teachers who are prepared to
have these difficult conversations then
Andrew Tates you know he will not be the
last of this kind of influencer he's
unique I'm afraid to say you know there
are young men my age that I have seen
certainly be influenced by the videos
that he puts out that posting them or
saying stuff like oh well he's got a
point here and buying into some of it
when you know that they buy into all of
it and that's concerning and I'm 24
years old and think about what kind of
inference you're going to have on on
young boys who are 9 10 11 12 you know
when they're early teens you're a very
impressionable time in your life anyway
so I think it's probably the case that
the department is going to come up need
to come up with something more robust
than uh just don't talk about it push it
away because it's not going to go away
and there will be more Andrew Tates in
the future yeah and interesting in this
article they talk about
um people saying my my dad likes him
though and the dad's coming in and
defending their children uh over it so
challenge for teachers there as well and
let's move on okay to an article in the
Sunday Express about social housing what
are they talking about here
they're talking about the lack of it and
really when we look at all those front
pages today talking about the nuances of
the coronation we think about the real
state of the nation this is the one of
the most challenging sets of figures
you'll read today
um the fact that nine out of ten
councils local authorities fail to to
build properties that are required that
are needed for social housing we know
that when the conservatives came in
there was a huge pledge to changes of
all this in 2019 and that's been
certainly watered down
um over recent years but we would just
have this ridiculous situation we've got
people that can't get on the property
ladder I think there needs to be huge
reform when it comes to things like
mortgages people paying so much in rent
they can't even begin to save deposits
for housing and then we've got people
who are desperately trying to get into
social housing and we're not building
anyone so when Keystone starts to talk
about this is an area where we need
reform this is an area we need change
you can't help to think that that might
be certainly freaking years of so many
that will be looking to him to perhaps
be our next leader for bringing the
labor party in if they're going to
deliver on this what I really worry
about is every time we read these
figures behind them and millions of
people in absolute misery who are in
housing that's just not adequate or
suitable who cannot find a way forward
or out of the situation they're in and
many many of them actually earning
enough to be able to buy a reasonable
property but not be just not bounce
across just not being able to get there
because the system financially will not
permit them to do so because the
deposit's required and the repayment
required and that where they've got to
meet uh the financial Benchmark that's
required it's just an awful bar instead
of it okay do you what would you pin the
reason why it's not happening down to
one thing I mean to what extent is that
the case that people generally might say
yeah we need more housing but they don't
actually want it built in their area is
that one of the problems one of the ways
that there's resistance you think Kate
it doesn't seem that it's just one thing
at all it is to do with multiple housing
ownership it's to do with the the cost
it's to do with the as you say the land
and sign off of the local councils and
and not to bully the local councils as
well who've been through three years of
just trying to do all they can to keep
local place going schools Etc with
dealing with everything from covert
onwards so no I think it is as we say
that perfect storm of issues but we need
governments in place that are actually
going to focus on this you can't do much
in life if you don't have solid
foundations of at least a home to be
able to set off from and try and build
the life you want to build okay yes and
lots of challenges people renting as
well and finding properties and prices
going up lots of challenges about around
housing aren't they let's move on to the
Sunday Telegraph of Thomas at their main
story today is um Kevin bednock getting
some support uh it says here on in her
war on wokery who's she getting it from
well interestingly the Sunday Telegraph
of sort of that the coronation is on the
front page but they're running with this
from Ron DeSantis the uh the governor of
Florida likely presidential hopeful
they've managed to buy an exclusive
interview with them it's two pages long
well worth the reads a couple of things
jump out one of them he came to the UK
as part of a multi-state visit
um sort of trying to advertise Flora
Authority and exports and business
around the world he was in Japan in the
UK at the end of his trip and elsewhere
he talked to James cleverly foreign
secretary and then the trade and
business secretary and that was when
this kind of line that they're running
with at the start is you know the war on
Rookery Rookery I'm commending that the
trade secretary on that basis Ronda
Santos has made a bit of a name for
himself on this kind of War on walk
thing
um he's been relatively controversial in
the states over stuff like Banning or
limiting what schools can teach pupils
about issues of gender he's taken on
Disney and Disneyland down in Florida
over similar issues not dissimilar to
that that can be bad knock in the UK has
had a bit of a fight against the likes
of gender-neutral toilets the likes of
and decolonizing the curriculum so it
was always going to be an area of
agreement the interesting the couple of
really well lines that maybe surprise
you the trade and business secretary
apparently told the Florida governor
that actually some of this was basically
America's fault and that this cancel
culture culture had emerged and had been
an ex an import from the United States
and he said that he was inclined to
agree with that so it was an interesting
fact probably on both sides of that and
you know an interesting conversation to
be having between the two of them
um the other thing that I mean Ron
DeSantis is going to be could be a
really significant International figure
he didn't meet with Richie shunak for
pretty obvious reasons if he decides to
enter the presidential race he's going
to have a horrifically better battle
against Donald Trump who certainly has
the majority the weight of support
within his party at the moment and he
would probably be probably be the
expected candidate but Ron DeSantis uh
you know could be could be huge or we
might forget him about him yeah indeed
it'd be interesting to see where that
one goes anyway we are out of time both
if you'd lovely to see you both this
morning
um and a reminder there's loads about
the coronation
um on the front pages as well which we
dealt with in the last hour but I'd love
to see both Kate and Thomas thanks very
much indeed
foreign
[Music]